well where are we with it all
nominations closed tomorrow and
candidates without enough support from
fellow MPs will be eliminated from the
contest the first ballot in the
leadership race will then be held on
Thursday and any candidate receiving 16
votes or fewer will be out the final
ballots will take place on June the 20th
until only two of those candidates
remain Conservative Party members will
then vote on their preferred candidate
and a new prime minister is expected to
be announced in late July
well the promises from the candidates
are coming in that thick and fast as you
might expect just today frontrunner
Boris Johnson claimed he would refuse to
pay the 39 billion pound bricks divorce
bill unless the EU offers better terms
while the Home Secretary Sajid Javid has
said that he would offer to pay hundreds
of millions of pounds for new
alternative arrangements on the Irish
border alongside Michael Gove submission
he'd committed a crime with his cocaine
use he also vowed to scrap v80 and the
former cabinet minister estimate they
refused to rule out temporarily
suspending Parliament in order to push
through a No Deal brexit